What is reddit?
For a large part of the internet, reddit is the gateway for everything
which is interesting in the world.
Reading Reddit.com is just like reading the newspaper, except that reddit
- current - interactive
- personalized - participating
- and sometimes terribly absorbent
... in short, * is good *.
How it works is that people submit links on reddit (blog posts, pictures or videos)
and other people vote these links up or down. It is a simple concept but it makes reddit
a list of the best things that people are now reading or watching on the Internet.
The name is a contraction of 'Read it' as in 'Read all', what, if you
Spends a lot of time on the site, you say to everyone
that you want to show something. It's a nice curse.
Because there are no editors on reddit you never know what you will find but you
can bet that it will be funny or interesting or outrageous because thousands of others
have voted that it is worth seeing.
Look at it this way: if Google is the place to look for things,
then reddit is the place where you go to see what people have found.
But reddit is not just one list of things: reddit is
a nice branch with parts, called subreddits.
If you only like politics or programming or funny pictures with inscriptions or sports or world news,
there are subreddits with only that subject. And there will probably be a subreddit for you
city, country or region.
Do you like a TV show that ended years ago? There is a subreddit that people are still talking about
as if it is just over.
Tech geeks have their technology and flag geeks have their vexillology and - on the
small chance that what you are interested in does not yet exist, you only have to press a button
and a new subreddit is born.
Each subreddit works as the main page: an updating list of interesting things according to
the people interested in those things.
And when a subreddit becomes large, it can become terribly good at it: for example, AWW,
a portion devoted to cuteness, a GLOBAL 24-HOUR BATTLE TO CUT THE MOST ADVERTISING PLATES
EVER!
If you give people with baby animal photos a place to compete with their baby animal photos
you get the highest density of cuteness that human civilization has created so far.
But without editors who manage the site, how does the sorting process work? There is no
time to dive into the code, but you can see it like this:
Links that people submit are balloons that float up and down the list. When someone
voting up a link enters a little helium and voting down takes out a little helium.
Every time reddit puts weights on all balloons - giving newer links a chance
get to fight against those who have been around a bit longer.
This method is bizarre good at sorting things, may it be international politics
or photos of computer setups.
Of course, when a site includes all human endeavors, weird things can pop up: such as subreddits
for only photos of birds ... with arms or only photos of Hitler ... with socks and then there are
always the other kind of photos that people like to look at and sometimes collections
of terrible things that can no longer be seen unseen
So yes, this has taken a bad turn. But remember that reddit can be weird not because
reddit is weird because people are weird. And the great thing about reddit is that
changes to you: when you participate in subreddits that you like and depart from that you don't like
the main page will be yours: a summary of the best of all subreddits you follow
and not the things you don't follow.
So reddit is like life: it is what you make it.
But links are only the top of the redditberg, because people can discuss the links and this
is where the true nature of reddit lies.
Most forums on the internet are ugly, but reddit is not your grandma's bulletin board.
Just as the balloon sorting method finds the best links, there is somewhat more difficult mathematics
(and less understandable) that finds the most interesting comment in a discussion and it
brings up. And reddit displays comments in such a way that it encourages discussions.
(Not like some * other * systems).
This sorting and threading ensures that the discussion of a link always
is more interesting than the link itself.
For example, there are subreddits that * are * only discussions: such as the Change My View for debates
or Ask A Scientist where experts answer questions. And there is 'IamA' where people say what they say
are "I am a firefighter" or "I am an escort" or "I am a prison officer" and answer questions
in the comment.
And because people are anonymous on reddit, discussions are always more interesting and open
then when you are forced to use your real name. :: kuch :: YouTube & Google+ Integration :: kuch ::
Although, with anonymity, you see that not everyone's private thoughts revealed are beautiful.
And sometimes it is unpleasant to see what a faceless group thinks about a subject.
But luckily reddit has a way to deal with unhelpful comments. And despite
it is clear to the people who behave badly that reddit can only exist because the majority
even while they are anonymous, is good.
However, this anonymity is not necessary, so you can also be actors, writers, presidents
and find prime ministers on reddit who answer community questions.
And reddit is really a community with its own culture and history and that one always
has a greater effect on the physical world with things like: meeting in real life and collecting money
for charity and defending the internet and helping a family with their sick child
and hold the world's largest lottery draw and send teachers the necessary materials.
With her lightning-fast democracy and shockingly fast responses, you can sometimes save
make you feel more like a resident of the internet than a resident of your own country.
But in the end it is difficult to understand reddit without just jumping in, commenting and
to vote, what you really should do. And once you get the hang of it, you will
you wonder how you ever used the internet for this.
[Credits]
PS If you already use reddit and you like the site, consider buying reddit gold
to support it. I was surprised to learn that while making this video it
increasingly popular it is still not profitable. So if you, like me, reddit
* used all day *, it is worth a few euros per month.